[Musique]
durant sept heures de confinement d'une
partie de notre cerveau est fortement
stimulée s'appelle l'air tegmentale
ventrale
c'est étonnant parce que dans des
expériences on a constaté que cette zone
s'active aussi bien quand on a été privé
de contact social pendant une journée
que quand on a été totalement privés de
nourriture
autrement dit le confinement la
privation de contact social est une
forme du jeune et c'est pas une jeune de
nourriture c'est un jeune social l'être
humain ne pouvait se nourrir dans des
situations hostiles pendant la période
paléolithique que en chassant en groupe
et quand en coopérant donc uniquement
les cerveaux doté d'une envie de
coopérer était avantagé pour survivre ce
qui explique que ce moteur du désir dans
notre ère tegmentale ventrale
aujourd'hui s'allume en situation de
confinement elle crie à l'aide elle
demande de la coopération et de la
socialisation
ça signifie que les rapports sociaux
sont essentiels à notre survie et ça
depuis très très longtemps ça c'est
gravé dans nos euros dont on a
absolument besoin
donc on va mobiliser cette partie de
notre cerveau qui crée un désir select
créer un désir de tout ce qui nous a
aidé à survivre manger coopérer aussi
évidemment et donc si on est privé de
contact social le risque c'est de se
rabattre vers de la nourriture ou de la
consommation compulsive addictives de
nourriture c'est un risque en
confinement voir la consommation
d'autres substances voire de drogue
ceux qui ont la malchance d'être confiné
seul se plaignent justement de ne plus
voir un visage réel ne plus entendre une
voix réelle
il ya quelque chose qui passe par la
présence en chair et en os d'une
personne qui n'est pas remplacé par le
numérique
il ya un aspect crucial de ce point de
vue là qui est le toucher puisqu'on sait
que la souffrance ni à la solitude est
très bien compensé par une un contact
physique
quelqu'un qui vous sert l'avant bras la
main qui passe une main sur votre épaule
qui vous serre dans ses bras et
énormément d'expérience qui ont montré
que ça ça fait reculer le sentiment
d'angoissé et même dans certaines
expériences la douleur physique des
expériences montrent par exemple que si
vous êtes soumis à des électrochocs et
que vous avez la possibilité de tenir la
main d'une personne qui vous est cher
la perception de la douleur diminue dans
cette situation de confinement on ne
peut pas satisfaire les désirs de base
notre cerveau notamment au niveau de la
socialisation mais aussi on peut pas
aller acheter tout ce qu'on veut dans le
commerce comme on est habitué à le faire
on ne peut pas bouger librement peut pas
voyager donc pour ça il faut quelque
part brider ses désirs profonds de notre
cerveau et pour brider cette activité du
désir de base il faut utiliser une
partie plus évoluée de notre cerveau où
siège la volonté le contrôle de soi et
ça s'appelle le cortex préfrontal donc
en cette période de confinement pour se
forcer à aller contre nos désirs
spontanées ont fait fonctionner à plein
régime
notre cortex préfrontal et on est obligé
évidemment de consommer beaucoup
d'énergie à ce niveau là il ya un risque
à force de lutter par la force de la
volonté et du cortex préfrontal contre
l'eire tegmentale ventrale pas d'avoir
des effets rebonds c'est à dire au bout
d'un moment que la force de la volonté
s'épuiser qu'on craque et que finalement
on donne libre cours philoreau à ses
désirs qui utilise une molécule qui
s'appelle la dopamine qui nous donne du
plaisir et qu'à ce moment là par exemple
on se jette en faisant des orgies de
séries télévisées ou en mangeant
beaucoup trop de nourriture grasse et
salé ça c'est un risque
en revanche il ya aussi un aspect
positif c'est qu'en faisant fonctionner
notre cortex préfrontal régulièrement de
cette façon ils se muscle il se
développe il retrouve une capacité quand
même d'autocontrôle qui peut-être a été
sous
exploité dans un monde où on pouvait un
peu satisfait à nos désirs librement un
des aspects qui sont les plus difficiles
à vivre aujourd'hui c'est la certitude
sur l'avenir le fait de ne pas savoir
combien de temps cette situation va
durer
ne pas savoir si l'épidémie sera
surmontée de ne pas savoir si nos
proches seront touchés l'incertitude est
quelque chose de très difficilement
gérable par le système nerveux humain
l'être humain est fait il ya même câble
et pour essayer de maîtriser son
environnement
c'est un peu ce qui a fait le drame de
notre civilisation c'est qu'on a tout
maîtrisé au point de tout contrôler et
d'animer la nature et de trop consommer
est d'arriver à une société qui est très
vulnérable aux épidémies par exemple
nous aimons savoir ce qui va arriver et
le contrôler et là nous ne contrôlons
plus nous avons une sorte de deux
blessures de fayat notre délire de toute
puissance et d'un seul coup on se sent
désarmé
cette incertitude est difficile à gérer
nous ne sommes pas faits pour ça
l'incertitude libère des hormones du
stress elle crée une angoisse et crée
parfois une angoisse existentielle et
face à cela nous sommes équipés
différemment selon notre tempérament il
ya des personnes qui tolèrent très bien
la certitude qu'ils peuvent admettre de
ne pas savoir de quoi demain sera fait
et ces personnes alors parfois sont dans
un excès d'insouciance on va les
retrouver aussi dans les parcs ou en
train de nier le fait qu' on est face à
une situation quand même très critique
et puis de l'autre côté vous avez des
personnes qui ne tolère aucun niveau
d'incertitude qui veulent tout contrôler
et cela bien sûr ceux qui vont se jeter
sur les pâtes et les papiers toilettes à
la première alerte
[Musique]